FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Hello,
I'm Florina Muntenescu
for The Developer Show.
This is your weekly update on
the Developer News from Google.
Application sand boxing is a
core part of Android design.
Isolating apps from each other.
In Android Q taking the
same fundamental principle
from applications sand boxing
we introduced scoped storage.
Take a look at this post for
best practices and updates.
Cloud TPUs were designed
from the ground up
to accelerate cutting edge
machine learning applications
from image recognition,
to language modeling,
to reinforcement learning.
And now we've made
it even easier
for you to use Cloud TPUs
for image segmentation.
With high performance TPU
implementations of two state
of the art segmentation models.
Mask R-CNN and DeepLab v3+.
The post has performance
and cost metrics
for both models along with
links to the GitHub repos.
Chrome 74 is now available.
And we've added support
for cleaner creation
of private class
fields in JavaScript
detecting when the
user has requested
a reduced motion experienced,
CSS transition events, and much
more.
Take a look at the post for the
change log and example code.
Data Saver is expanding
to provide more benefits
in addition to data savings.
Pages will now load faster, in
some cases considerably faster
and use less memory.
It will now be called Lite mode.
And you can read
more on the post.
Google I/O is next week.
We'll be taking a
break from the TLDR
because the whole Dev Show crew
will be on site hanging out
at the sessions and sandboxes.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Florina Muntenescu
for the Developer Show.
Thanks for watching and
we'll see you at Google I/O.
We can do better, come on.
SPEAKER 1: Dev Show
DS155 take four.
[MUSIC PLAYING]